Chief business correspondent Christine
Romans is here with us.
Christine,
if you weren't paying attention
on Friday
afternoon, you were off work
or on a trip,
break down
exactly what happened
here would be the anatomy
of a collapse of a big bank
and the anatomy of a rescue
from the federal government.
Let's look at how we got here.
First of all, what is as VB?
It is the epicenter of tech startups,
venture capital, Silicon Valley Bank.
It is the 16th largest bank
or it was in the United States
and this is really
the oxygen for technology.
The technology sector
really goes through SVP.
So a very important
bank here by the end of 20, 22.
It had $175 billion in total deposits.
And here is the anatomy of the bank run.
Right. This is how much money it had.
End of the year.
Just on Thursday
there were $42 billion
in withdrawals from depositors. Right.
So something happened here
where people want to take their money out
and this bank unraveled here.
So what happened? Why did they get there?
Well, this is a company
that for years took deposits
in the good times
when interest rates were very low
and it grew and grew and grew
and those deposits grew.
And it put that money
into long dated treasuries,
into treasuries, safe,
super safe treasuries. Right.
So this is how much they had
at the end of 20,
22, $128 billion worth of of Treasury.
Look at
that is amazing how much it gained.
But then as things started to go south,
when interest rates were rising,
those were less valuable
and the company actually
was selling those treasuries at a loss.
When that word got out.
People got nervous.
The stock in the bank started to decline.
Depositors started to withdraw their
their money.
They were also withdrawing their money
because technology
that sector was in a downturn. Right.
So instead of putting money
into the bank,
depositors are taking money
out of the bank and the bank
could not sustain it.
Come to the rescue.
The United States government,
the FDIC, is going to insure up
to $250,000 in normal times.
And now you're
going to have this facility
so that above that level,
everyone will be made whole,
not the bondholders
and not the stockholders of the bank,
we should point out,
but the people who have their deposits
in that bank, also signature bank.
This is the other
the other shoe to drop this weekend.
This is a bank
that specializes in services
for law firms
It also got into big trouble.
The government will also back
the depositors there.
So a really important
weekend of developments, you guys.
This could have been
a very different morning.
A very different morning
if we didn't have the Treasury
and the Fed working all weekend
to try to make sure
that folks were made whole.
And and I'll say this is because
interest rates rose
so dramatically as something
was going to break in the economy. Right.
And this is what broke, guys.
And that comes as the Fed
chair is only warning
that federal interest rates
are going to continue
to rise
Christine Romans
will wait to see what the markets
say when they open. Thank you.
With us now, CNN business correspondent
Michelle Solomon
and Wall Street Journal senior
special writer Justin Baer.
It just by the way, Justin's
latest reporting is headlined
How Silicon Valley Turned on
Silicon Valley Bank.
So good to have both of you on.
You know, I was reading your notes
and what you wrote about this.
You have been very strong about this.
And at the end, tough
on what you call
you are calling this a bailout.
You said there's
no other way of putting it.
This is a bailout.
No matter what terminology
you want to use. Yeah.
Why are you saying that?
Well, it's I mean, clearly,
there are some that
that are getting bailed out. Right.
You know, the depositors of these these
these particular banks are
many of which are companies. Right.
They need to make payroll.
The money was trapped
in these institutions.
And so the government
took extraordinary actions
to allow them to access that money.
Right.
Even even as those banks
were going through receivership and
and had failed.
So whether the taxpayer money
was used to to
to implement those plans,
the government said no.
But but clearly, there was a rescue
of a particular group
of people and businesses.
So one of the things that M.J.
noted
that's really important
is what
the government's doing now
and they're setting up this emergency
lending facility.
So part of the reason
the city got into a lot of trouble
is that they had to sell these long
term treasuries at a loss.
Then they went out to try to capital
raise last Wednesday,
spooked the policy
to try to get $2 billion.
And they saw and depositors
well, and investors saw the loss
and pulled out money.
And so you're selling these at a loss
because interest rates have gone up.
Your securities aren't as
attractive anymore.
This what the government's doing
now would prevent against someone else
having to do a capital raise like that.
Right? Right.
That's exactly it.
Banking is all about confidence, right?
Confidence in the system.
Confidence that if you or I
or anyone here at this
table puts their money into a bank,
if we need it tomorrow,
that money will be there.
What happened here
with SVB was a lack of confidence.
And so you started to see
all of these depositors rush
to get all of their money out.
And that's what led to this panic.
So what the Fed is trying to do
and what regulators are trying to do here
is to prevent that from happening again.
Right.
Sort of
insulate the riskier
insulate the contagion
so that this doesn't spread
beyond and sob story.
And that's why you saw officials
in layman's terms, this an old fashioned
is it an old fashioned
run on the bank as well?
Absolutely. 100%.
And I mean, you know,
I spoke to a founder
who had a lot of her money
in this bank last night,
and she said that,
you know,
the tech community is very smart
that this founder
community is very small.
She said early last week,
text messages were starting to go around.
It became chatter.
And as the days went on, screenshots
were going around in terms of,
hey, my investors have pulled your money.
And so it really did lead to
a high tech problem in terms of tech,
but really leading to an old fashioned
home front.
I think Patrick McHenry from North
Carolina said it was a Twitter
fueled bank run
because they were all these old,
very online people who were all talking
about those messages.
This $250 cap,
they're basically waiving it
with the steps
that we're seeing yesterday.
I think over
90% of SB vs SB
these funds were uninsured.
So are they going to permanently
raise it now?
Is it just completely ineffective?
What is even the point of the $50,000?
I mean that's, that's
the open question, right?
Because I think some of the,
some of the added steps, including that
that fund that was established
is there to support
other banks
if they find themselves
in a similar situation, right.
They can borrow from the government,
they can
post collateral at par, essentially
making it a lot
less expensive in order to borrow.
And in the event
that there is some kind of run.
But yeah,
but in this case
they decided to waive
what, you know, blow plow.
Right through that deposit insurance cap.
And in allowing these
what are essentially
in most cases, companies, right, that
that have it a lot of money
at these institutions.
Are you surprised that they didn't
get acquired over the weekend?
I think that was
that was certainly part of the
part of the process. Right.
So the FDIC had
initiated an auction for SBB,
didn't it?
Obviously, there
was no
there was no winning
bid for that auction.
I think it's possible
that we could see other assets
that get sold in the coming days.
We saw overnight or rather this morning
HSBC step in and by the U.K.
arm of Silicon Valley Bank so, you know,
there are other interesting businesses
in both of these these banks
that that could warrant some interest.
It could be some more deals that we see.
Yeah, I think they said that JP Morgan
and PNC among the suitors,
SVB Holding Company,
which would exclude the SBB Bank
Bank part of it.
But I think
you raise a very good question about what
this new said about
when you took the question
about the feds,
whether the feds will listen to
what has been said,
stop raising rates,
because this this contributed to it.
Everyday folks are concerned about this.
This isn't just tech people.
This isn't just people
who have private equity.
This affects
all aspect, all aspects of the economy.
So if people are at home or hell
and they're sitting there
wondering as they have been all weekend
and I affected by this.
What do you say to them?
Look, it's a great question.
I mean, I think we are all so connected
in terms of banking.
I think the big difference here is that
this was largely
a very sort of insulated bank. Right.
A big bank, nonetheless,
but sort of focusing on a specific sector
of the economy, a very mature
public is a
very important part of the economy,
but a secular,
sort of insulated part of the economy.
I think the reason why the Fed stepped up
as quickly as they did
is to prevent the risk to people
like everyone watching at home. Right.
To protect other regional banks
so that we have confidence
in the banking system
and that's why we saw the type of
rapid response that we did.
I don't know just and I mean,
you point
first year public was down like 30%
that we have images
of these long lines of people
going to first republic over the weekend
trying to take money out there
they're standing that signature's not
and these are not just banks
that cater to Silicon Valley.
You wrote in your piece
about how this exposes
some of the vulnerabilities
that we still have.
Sure.
As you said earlier
I mean, this all based on confidence.
Right.
And the calm
in the whole financial system.
Any financial institution
is dependent on that,
on the ongoing confidence.
So once that's lost or once
it becomes lost,
it can lead to what we saw this
this past week. Right.
And that can
that can flare up elsewhere very quickly,
which again, is
why you saw the government
go beyond
just looking at these two institutions
over the weekend,
but saying, well, how do we avoid
seeing other lenders,
particularly those that
that, again,
the regulations have changed
over the past decade
with respect to smaller
and medium sized banks.
How can we protect and insulate
those not only those banks,
but more importantly,
their customers are smaller,
medium sized banks?
Or is it because they're holders
of a lot of mortgages, for example?
I mean, all the above, right?
You know, so so
you know, every about every bank
balance sheet
is going to look
a little bit differently.
Right.
I mean,
everyone has had to deal
with the impact of rising interest rates.
Some did.
So obviously
a lot more prudently than than others.
Right. Right.
And so there will be others
that will resemble in some ways
the way Silicon Valley Bank looked.
Right.
You and we see some of the other names
get very quickly
attached to what happened
to them last week.
But but again, we'll have to see.
It's all based on confidence.
It's going to be interesting
to see what happens
as we get closer to the markets
and the day the banks start opening up.
And some of them
have actually opened up higher.
I mean, some of them
have actually been higher on this event.
We're going to be watching that.
The president's going to speak.
There's going to be a lot to deal with
with this.
Thank you, Michelle. Thank you.
Justin, we appreciate that.